boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still in Boston Massachusetts we are
very excited to be talking about a bunch
of different things related to
neurobiology related to all different
types of interesting subjects I'm super
excited to be sitting down with Sarah
new shhhhh bobak anova hello thank you
so much for having me tonight thank you
for coming on so appreciate it very
excited very excited and we've been
having some great conversations and I'm
looking forward to learning more about
your story sharing your story with other
people sharing your interests and what
you want to build into this world we're
really excited let's do this so tell us
about yourself
well my name is Sarah nose it's a very
heartening for some people to say but I
don't I don't make friends with people
who don't take a little bit of time and
take a few neurons and their brains to
memorize it so I think everyone should
be proud of their roots that's what I
tried to make it was this point and what
do you want to hear about myself I'm
just a human simple like everyone I
don't think that anyone is like
different from each other much but we're
different enough to be interested in
each other and I'm very very excited
about this opportunity because this
opportunity sauce not just like kind of
interview with me but through the same
very excited also to learn more things
about myself and also about you and
about yes
because this kind of like makes me think
about the audience who we talked to
through this interview so like it's also
making me to realize themselves what the
audience about myself and about the
people that we do our work for because
eventually like we're not just in vacuum
doing our own thing who wouldn't be a
human if if I did not have other humans
with who we grew up so basically me is
not just myself but also like all these
other people and influences and people
who gave the memories that I had and
people who gave knowledge that they had
and emotions that they had and that what
makes me what makes my neural network to
give me experiences that this brain gets
from
probably the same things that you get
but like I process it the way I do so
that's what makes me I can tell you more
about the people and things that I went
through that made me who I am but that's
I love how you already took us into this
realm of thinking so first of all yes
you're a new people got to know how to
say names that are not Bob and John and
Sally and Kim you know there's got it
you know you gotta know how to say
different names from around the world it
gives you a better taste of reality at
its fullest diversity and then you also
said that there's an interesting that
humans are just different enough to be
interested in each other but humans are
humans were just evolved on this rock
together and we're now figuring things
out about where we can hopefully prosper
with love and then yeah so tell us more
about about you in terms of like you
were saying like you have this unique
mind as everyone has a unique mind
unique stimuli have filled their mind
right so that makes everyone unique in
that sense their minds unique but then
we have this unique perspective that you
and I have been sharing as well that is
fantastic if we have the language to
exchange those and you know it's
fantastic to have that opportunity to
like that I say something and you
actually understand me even though like
how your brain perceives world is just
you know like just electrical signals
that kind of like makes a hallucination
and a very limited thing that it gets
through very limited range of you know
things that every sense gets to the
brain so I don't know yeah that's
actually like let's celebrate it so we
have the language and actually word it
is a very weird phenomenon that we can
talk to each other and make sense of
what seems to be a reality from one
perspective in a different perspective
thank goodness for how we've evolved
here and how we have so many privileges
that we get to live with it's such a
blessing okay so so alright so now we're
we're talking about how you went you and
I and a bunch of people that we
typically surround ourselves with have
abstract perspective on reality
and you have sort of built yourself this
abstract perspective on reality by
getting yourself involved in a lot of
different things at young ages
especially like the sciences and
competitions this is very exciting stuff
to teach us about this yeah so I am a
proud citizen of Hermia my else efforts
from Georgia Russia Iran probably also
Israel as I know so much as we can know
and I mean in one sense it gives
something in other sense people think
that they're very you know like citizens
of the of the of the of the world they
don't need to be tied to someplace but I
think having those experiences of those
nations kind of like being with each
other having some relationship having
this opportunity to be a breach for them
because you're not really there isn't in
order to be there so you kind of have to
balance gives you enough power and you
know understanding about how the world
works to actually be able to contribute
later on so that's what I grew up was I
had to kind of like balance in between
those and also parallel to that balance
in between the things that were
economically not stable at the times
when I was born in those states again
post-soviet countries and all the
economical differences in 90s and early
2000s and were born there right after my
family left a couple years after my
family was and after a little bit more
time what's the my family left so I was
like oh yeah it was very hard yeah but I
mean probably like one of the something
that can probably would personalize my
experience for you and our audience
would be like imagine our house didn't
have light and we didn't have heat in
our house so that for us gave an
opportunity to open air windows and
there was no light pollution on the
streets and also it was like kind of the
same because it was winter it was cold
in house and outside the house so it was
you know it wouldn't matter to open the
windows and we were studying astronomy
and looking at the Stars and being like
you know amazed by them and those are
like my brightest memories I don't
remember the cold and you know lack of
food and stuff like that but I
inspiration by like beauty and arts and
science that was you know taught to me
in that you know situation of like
absolute you know like no food no
electricity anything so probably that's
what kind of like you know if you go
through that then like and through a
couple of things like that then it's
like a little bit hard to break you
afterwards because you really know what
is important if you yeah so for me
important things where the arts the
sciences and being able to make those
connections and comprehend them at some
higher level and and just you know it
was just joy to be with them and all the
competitions that you mentioned like I
mean again we can list down but I don't
think it's important to list them
because um you know they were just the
consequences of me just trying to you
know spend my time was those things that
I loved and then that was just kind of
like secondary it came through that and
it came also through of course not just
like me wanting those things but also
like the collective you know of course
everyone competes for his own medal for
his own gold but you you have so much
better results and so much better
memories if you actually kind of like
working team you push through things
together you share and you go through
struggles together so those are the
things that made me who I am not like
the things that are on my resume like
the the end points of like I got gold or
I got bronze or whatever so yeah that's
so important that you bring this up this
point of being driven by insatiable
curiosity in certain fields and that
drive actually you made that point about
the drive earlier as well about how if
you've set your goal on on achieving an
objective that is solely I have to
achieve this objective and you become so
attached to this one aspect of it rather
than being having a strong desire for
something like just curiosity in that
domain you things kind of fall more into
place for you if you just have that
curiosity in that door
and want to explore an experience of
life okay so as you study and this is a
really interesting perspective that you
bring up about about about astronomy and
just about like living somewhere where
it's the same temperature outside as it
is inside in a cold environment because
I think we talk about so much but we're
just not fully aware of our privileges
because we don't really look back in
time of civilization evolving to get
here enough and we don't really
understand the hard work that people
went through in order to give us
electricity and heat and Internet and
all these tools and texts that we have
now we don't even acknowledge some of
the things that already have been done
and they actually worked very well at
those times those papers just happen
forgotten those things you know those
nodes or knowledge exist it's just no
one's making edges between them no one's
making edges of them with the current
technologies that exist today to make
today's technology stronger you know
like synergize on those things to
develop some of the things that would
cure cancer like I don't know fight was
the differences in socioeconomic status
of people or establishing democracy not
by using iron and using bombs and stuff
like that but you think actually some
like you know noble technologies for
that purpose so yeah there is a lot of
work that we could do and everything is
like available for us we're just like
not connecting the right ages ago right
time and I think the main problem for
that and that's been also like I want to
credit all the people who I'm getting
this ideas from it was in one of the
conversation of my pee I was me that we
are kind of like trying to do our next
steps in our lives based on the skills
that we already have but we don't need
to like think about the skills to think
about what next step to undertake like
again that was also a big struggle of me
trying to connect astronomy and biology
while I was like a high schooler and
simultaneously trying to become
ballerina and people were like oh are
you crazy like how are you going to like
do well and all of them but I proved
that like you know everything
same because the world like seems the
same for me the art the way you meditate
and dance or the way you you know see
math in creation of the biological
systems or creation of the physical
systems and the stars are like super
similar and like by just looking at them
from very abstract a little bit more
abstract perspective you can understand
and excel them all and they can actually
help you to understand the other one
much better because you apply the
methods from studying the other one to
yes that idiot next one yes that's that
multidisciplinary lens of seeing the
world and it's also you brought this up
this really beautiful knowledge
accumulation a collective learning that
we've had as a society and furthermore
is you have an opportunity everyone has
an opportunity to be able to figure out
what we in the past have learned and
then potentially forgotten to apply in
our I think one of those things is the
collective it's a cult feeling of a
stronger collective unity amongst each
other potentially who knows who knows
and maybe I think maybe there were times
before where we felt a deeper more
divine connection to each other and to
something that transcended us and I
think a lot of the vanity metrics and
narcissism metrics have sort of hurt us
in many ways
yeah so building on the fact that you
started doing this multidisciplinary
perspective and lens and hustling a lot
your different interests areas you ended
up applying to come to the United States
and study at schools here in the u.s.
yeah so again that might be some kind of
like name dropping you know I go here I
could I talk to this people I'm under
this professor but and for some people
maybe this is a goal you know like they
try to like get in here and for me it
was more of like mm let me try and prove
myself that I can you know I either can
make it or maybe it waits for me at some
other stage of my life let's check
whether this is the right time for me to
be in this place and of course first one
of the things that I would like to
mention is that like people should not
be afraid of going into spaces that they
have absolutely no experience and if you
really want to be there your passion is
enough to study and do well in that I
know I knew no English I knew no way to
write you know letters about myself I
knew no way of writing essays about
myself that are you know like qualified
for this universities I knew no way to
study in medical school and work on
three jobs to have the money to apply to
this universities I knew no way how to
deal with things like you know miss
diagnosis of cancer and waiting for your
application results and you know way how
to get into MIT was your science
recommender not submitting his science
recommendation which has like required
for you to be at MIT and you know I was
just honest was what I'm doing and like
what I want to do and that was just
enough for people to recognize me and it
was right for me and it was logical step
for me to be here at that time and you
know it was not like fanatic dream for
me to get into here or be somewhere and
I don't want for anyone to have that
fanatic dream because it can be very
destroying if you don't get into there
if you are really good and like doing
something and you are good because
you're passionate about it then at some
point I don't know you'll come here as
an undergrad or you will be with this
professors because they are leading
people in this field as a grad student
or you'll come for some problem or you
just send them a letter and they will
pay for you and the you come and do
research here or you will become a
professor yourself we'll find a company
or you know you just talk about it on a
media and you'll come and interview them
and then just like you know be wisdom
and actually spend time with them more
than their students do so like there is
absolutely no limitation on you being
anywhere you just like identify the
problem that you want to solve and try
to find the best way that you're like
opportunity the space of your
opportunities allows you to get there
and then that way eventually would be
very close to places like MIT
or probably some other places where
super genius people who are not listed
on this top ranked places but are you
know like very interesting people and
you will talk to them eventually if you
you know just follow your passions and
of following some names so that was my
lesson from this even though I got into
somewhere but you know that wasn't what
I took it's such a good story it's such
a good story it there's we forget we
forget about sometimes the the
difficulty that that you know you're in
your specific story the difficulty that
sticks out to me is like a misdiagnosis
of with cancer a Bingle one even be yeah
yeah there's a lot in this is a big
decision
there's a big uprising that's going on
in terms of just adoring the feminine
energy and being totally yeah I love
that it's time here we go I'm serious
there's gonna be a really beautiful
synergy with both of them that's coming
up that's this very strong feeling that
I have yeah absolutely
and that and then you know not you know
not having a scientific letter in not
happy absolutely like fluent in that is
your primary language and figuring out
how to write that adequately competing
in so many different you know the three
jobs at the same time as trying to get
over here you know this is these are the
struggles that people from like you and
people from around the world in many
ways go through in order to like you
said you have something in mind a
problem that you want to solve where you
want to go îsh and you just got you
would go and you and you find different
diverse past explore and figure it out
and then things you know kind of
collapse in on that one path and you go
with that one and that's why you find
yourself now at MIT in Boston and
Cambridge and here and and and here you
are you're okay so you're now and you're
you're going in your third I mean my
treating your ear like in the middle of
my junior year
sitting physics and electrical
engineering computer science yes as
macca demyx and i work was at a point
instead neurobiology solution so this of
course we can we can say whatever we
want
okay so so so physics and now how did
you decide that electrical engineering
computer science and physics how do you
how do you find out that that's you know
where you want to steer yourself well
that will also come from like my
personal like again storing my fears and
the place where i met there are not many
women in the sciences and especially in
my family where my both parents are
mathematicians and at the time it was
kid burden etics and applied mathematics
what we called yeah
computer science right now especially my
dad who was like super talented in this
unfortunately both my parents couldn't
continue their academic paths because of
the economic situation of the country
different all the countries but because
of you know this authority i was an and
patriarchal place where I'm coming from
even though they are very supportive I
always felt like you know I'm a little
bit scared of touching meThe very firmly
being very close to it because you know
there are always people around me who
are so much better than me so like I was
just like a little bit kind of like
trying to walk around it like iron
austere physics biology chemistry things
surrounded not really touching the math
and computers and I just was born and
like when I was like 2 years old I was
like just surrounded physicists micro
schemes and wires and I was like so
horrified of them I didn't know how to
connect them what goes where
why did thing responds to me like
telling it something and I was just like
so scared of that some form of
intelligence I don't know something that
does something it's kind of intelligent
like this toy that I have no idea how
can I control it so for the longest time
I was actually kind of waiting even
though I was like good at maths and when
I was pushing computer science I was
good at it for me
when I came to MIT I knew that there's
so much to the beautiful mathematical
and physical tools and just like the
understanding of the world as in physics
I don't consider myself the genius and
physics absolutely not there are so many
more people there you know like so much
better than me and they have like this
background but like I'm just like so
passionate by the way how it teaches me
to see the world and it's like so
beautiful to like see how the math works
such that it makes the world as it is
right now and how you can use it to
control for example biological systems
to program them to make them do what you
want them to do and biological systems
basically you as human it's like you
know something conscious or it is some
kind of you know system that is made of
something else I mean whatever it is
quantum computer or some kind of
computer that also has some form of
intelligence or may have some form of
voltage you can kind of control it in
some ways and it's like just so
mesmerizing again I started from physics
and I mean my background allowed me to
do a little bit research and like
biological stuff but then I also like
kind of pushed myself and it was like
okay I'm gonna like really try to learn
computer science oh I don't care about I
mean that it's it's still like levels
and steps of realization because you can
get trapped very quickly at MIT that's
all you need to do two pagers or you
need to like write a senior thesis all
you need to apply for a PhD I try to you
know ground myself to my actual nature
and remember that nothing of this
actually matters and what I need to do
is actually just take classes and just
be with people and cool professors and
cooties and ting professors that I just
want to like click with and just have
like really nice conversations with and
if like some kind of majors to come out
or if I want to like continue doing what
I do and if it makes sense for me to you
know get a fellowship and get into a PhD
or something I will do that but like
it's like so much secondary for then
being kind of like you know
understanding this thing's clicking was
dispise connection in the middle of the
night wisdom or I mean in the middle of
the piece I think night
we solve some problems or connect with
my peers on those problems or trying to
identify the problem or after you
identified it trying to find the best
way for you to like get to solve the
right portion of that or the life right
level of abstraction to contribute to
that and yeah so that's where I am right
now I mean it says that I'm studying
that but like this is what I'm actually
like pushing myself to do it's really
it's really hard yeah it's really hard
but you you nailed it there with
surrounding yourself with other really
smart people and knowing that as you do
that you kind of aim to be a problem
solver amongst your groups and you aim
to be an abstract thinker filling
yourself in in areas that maybe have a
way that you can help contribute and
that you can for sure to learn and ask
questions about and that's a really good
way to end up you know finding yourself
in a place that can at times be a little
bit cutthroat in terms of you know make
sure that you get take as much value
from people as possible and make sure
that you have everything that you have
figured out for your next steps a PhD or
industry wherever you're going next so
it's good to take that you know okay
well who are the top five people I want
to connect myself to it yeah how can I
you know slowly start learning for
people like that and so taking maybe a
different approach to a kind of a
standardized system of how you go
through academia yeah it's been a
blessing she like connect to all those
peers that even drop out of this school
you know like who drops out of MIT well
very nice people do actually do that and
they I mean some of them are like some
of the most inspirational people for me
that like when did their own thing and I
mean my perception of how my
contribution maybe also changed like
back in my previous years I thought that
I cannot tribute only in academia but I
mean being an entrepreneur and starting
something and helping to organize people
to also find those values and all those
things that I mentioned for myself in
themselves can be also a very right
abstraction level to contribute at and
well eventually I think I hope that I
mean I I think just like
personality-wise I may feed him to that
as well so like I'm trying myself and
that kind of work as well right now yeah
yeah and so it's almost as though you're
you're constantly surrounding yourself
with different groups of people that are
pushing the boundaries of knowledge
what's known and then you kind of you
you kind of play and dance with them by
hitting these these balls of ideas back
and forth until you scrape at the
boundary of knowledge and you're like
whoa that was cool has anyone thought of
that before can we potentially send that
over to other people and see what they
say about it and that type of stuff
that's how collective learning happened
in many ways how the knowledge
boundaries were pushed it wasn't pushed
by people that sat around and did
nothing with their time it was people
that relentlessly wanted to know what
the next thing was that humans didn't
know over and over again and actually
you probably brought up a good point in
your in your story as well about how
when there was just for you you were
already around a bunch of different you
know your parents and your parents were
already inspiring you in some ways for
you to explore math computer science I
went up but again it's just we sometimes
we just need and this happens so often
in people of all different types of
socioeconomic statuses from all around
the world just need a little bit of
enthusiasm from someone if we see like
another woman or another person of a
different status than us that are in a
position of of being in computer science
or in math or whatever and we're like
wait a second I can do that too and
they're like you can do this too go do
that you're playing with this get used
to it it's explore it
that's so needed in our world and we're
slowly getting there
yes exciting okay sometimes you don't
even need to like have those people to
push the boundaries and create new notes
but as I said some of the notes or so
many knows already exists it just needs
people to make the right connections and
so many discoveries are you know just
made by chance
because those edges were not thought
like okay why is this very similar to
that white this can contribute to this
and they together it can be something I
mean VR was done so much earlier than
magiclip existed or I don't know the
first touch pad was done so much earlier
than the first iPad existed like why why
some of the things become viral so much
later well maybe today some of the
technology allows us to push those
things and true cancer or do something
and there is knowledge from 70s or 60s
already existing there it's just like
we're not leaking that thing was the
technology that we have today - just
like produce that thing very easily
well doesn't take much it's great it's
great how you're you're in the last
couple of decades and my mind for a
moment went - well what about from 2500
years ago the meditation the ability to
- to understand that the self is an
illusion the ability the ability to
become one with everything the ability
to really feel that feeling then what
then what if we were putting that into
all our exponential technologies today
into our geopolitical discussions of the
United Nations today why has that
lineage been so distracted and
distraught in so many ways because okay
I want to I want to go to I want to go
to this because I don't I want to make
sure we're like we're deep in knowledge
graph the knowledge that I love it
because we were talking about that so
much and it's such an important subject
but I want it I want to I want to see
where you where you take us here because
I this actually has a lot to do with the
knowledge graph and especially the outer
ring neurobiology we don't really get
that much about it quite yet we're
starting to understand the universe in
here and in the inner workings of our
biological mechanisms or starting to get
it there's a lot of cutting-edge stuff
going on in this field a ton and so what
are you what do you like what are you
exploring in that outer edge right now
well you you trapped me or like we
having this conversation at the
crossroad of my life right now when I
need to decide which way which level or
extraction
or which particular path am i choosing
to contribute I know the problem that I
want to want to solve I want to help
people probably physically like be able
to augment themselves why one person
should be disadvantaged from going to
space or living an extreme environment
of having AI near him by just you know
not being smart enough not being fast
enough or not having you know the
radiation protection has gained or not
having the right liver to process the
right things not being able to see
infrared for some reason why can't we
change ourselves and make the decisions
after where were not by having
Christopher before you know like before
where form embryos well one of the ways
to do that is to be able to control the
biological systems and program them and
you know help assemble them in a ways
that we can later transplant or like
import somehow or like change the
biological sins by injecting something
in your body so this is very like
physical method and the other ways like
you are computational which is you know
being able to teach machines and the
intelligence machine to be more
biological more human-like and
especially the learning which is more
important in machines to be more
human-like so the link between them
because we it is much easier we don't
want to fight them in the end we want
them and us to be able to synergize with
the choice have a symbiosis with each
other and have our interaction with them
at higher bandwidths and have them also
more powerful because they may help us
solve some of the more like humanitarian
questions and more important questions
just for the survival of the humankind
yeah there's there's a lot that you
started unpacking there first is the
augmentation side of things it's great
to hear you being really passionate
about that because it's a hundred
thousand plus people die every single
day and there's a lot of creativity
that's being lost that we have just a
little bit more time for people could
give them the potential to contribute
more to the knowledge graph of humanity
and it could give them those last bits
of relationships that they want to
develop with their with their loved ones
that they weren't able to because they
potentially didn't get it done in the
time period of the world be able to
preserve yourself in some form even
after you die or be able to connect with
other people and just merge in other
people why do we have to use the
language to communicate with each other
why can't I just connect to you when you
just like have all my emotions and
actually leave everything that I went
through yeah yeah and that's sort of the
secrets that we have from each other not
really like in the Biggers
well those yeah that's right in the
biggest yeah exactly
open open up my everything and then you
know what do you what do you
decentralize everyone's everything then
what then it's like oh we have blackmail
what what's the your blackmail is
useless
there's no everyone is loving and caring
and progressing so your blackmail is
useless so totally the open opening up
of the neural networks of each human
being or well it's sci-fi now and then
it becomes reality soon and it's it's
interesting to see that transition so as
you talk about augmentations I also
found it to be exciting that the way
that you you know the way that you think
about this is is a you think about
things in a very like high-level picture
about how we can move towards making
sure that we can have more of the bodily
functionalities that we need for longer
periods of time I'm curious how do we do
that at the micro level doing like what
are the best ways to make sure that we
can have the proper skin or have the
proper organs or have the proper what we
need to to move on we are very bad right
now in being able to make organs or add
functionality to existing organs and I
believe that it's really important for
people to be able to have choice what to
do with themselves after they're born so
instead of changing your babies and
deciding the color of their eyes I think
a more interesting thing would be okay
the person's already grown up I decided
that I need to go to Mars well I'm not
an astronaut I don't have like the
health or
I need to have I want to go to some kind
of like distant stars so I need to like
age slowly for that all right I need to
preserve myself somehow so that would
look more like okay let me kill eat my
liver or lead to my eyes and then
replace them with something else that
gives me like more information about the
things I can actually super eyes yeah
super liver surprise super skin and I
don't know be able to connect yourself
with the spaceship or I connect yourself
with the computer that you work was at
home that you can actually emotionally
feel when something is broken or when
that data is not present processing
correctly you can send signals in higher
bandwidth or you see if I can get this
so your your on the degrees of freedom
boat you love being able to give people
what they potentially would want so so
if for example if there are people that
want to just be their biological selves
like totally cool like be just your
biological self but for those that do
want orientations you're gonna have a
lot of selection we're gonna have a lot
of selection available for people to be
able to actually potentially want to who
want to go to Mars or who just want to
have supervision here on earth or who
want to be able to connect to everything
that is all the time you know it's all
about perception like if you want to
feel like you're living a longer life
like as fly does it feels that the time
actually is like slower because this is
the life span is so short can we
actually make the people believe that
they are living longer but just not
making them live longer it's a little
bit hard with length I'm communicating
to other people because other people are
super slow further than that but like
you know also playing first dose why do
we have to feel that you know like we
see you and like but why don't we have
to feel some other things in everybody
why can't we like consciously feel that
we don't have enough insulin or blood
and then consciously make our Pinecrest
to produce more insulin so like you know
things like that is there in any way to
like connect our brain just better with
our body without any augmentation
basically like making more edges in the
nose that we already have in the graph
of her yes that's right
that okay so there's so many there's so
many cool ways to take this
okay you also had some time doing intern
work with NASA which is very exciting
in exoplanet work and it was analyzing
with chemical compositions yes here's
you know it was it was a blessing to
work on that first of all because it was
my first major exposure to computer
science because I was actually modeling
trying to model what Fortran II was just
like a language I know if nowadays most
of computer science know about that
that's what physicists use and then the
other one is that you know there are
many ways to do things and then that
particular internship taught me that you
know there even at the larger scale
actually like finding lives on other
planets
you can't build a thirty billion
telescope or you can feel like 1 million
telescope and still be able to reach
enough accuracy to detect that so what
are the smart ways how can you treat the
system of physics and chemistry how can
you actually see the model and also
connected to the economic you know
opportunities of your company for
example NASA how to you know make make
your decision based not just of abstract
things so what we can do but actually
what is the minimum leader to do to get
like very high result so that's what I
got from that and of course I love
astrobiology next planets because I was
always trying to connect the my earlier
like astronomy like astrophysics and
like biology in some way so yeah that
was the first my attempt than space
medicine now it's like more and you know
just extreme environments and human
centric that you bring up this really
again a really good point about if you
can figure out how to more
cost-effectively probe the universe into
pro biologists systems or whatever it
may be the you can gain so many more
trials in cannibal yeah yeah testing
because a decrease in cost of 30 X means
30 times more tests on different ways
that you want to probe and explore Wow
yeah that's so important so to actually
have the smart people around you that
are thinking outside of the box
we talked about that a good amount as
well maybe that that's actually quite
important to bring up tell tell us about
your experience here because we've we
know we've had a couple people now that
are at MIT Harvard Berkeley Stanford etc
on the show and we'd like to ask about
what their experiences were like at the
institutions that they're like what is
it like talking to other students here
because you know you're you're like you
know you're the first person from
Armenia to come and do an undergrad your
first person of Armenia to go and do an
internet ass you know this is these are
very cool things you're setting a
precedent for other people to say I can
do that too I can do that too and go and
then when you get here you're like
there's so many other smart people
everywhere around here from different
countries that are all there first
people and stuff
so what does that transition like when
you get here and what has it evolved to
the night last couple of years so it
might be intimidating again if you think
about it and like just you know oh did
you get a gold medal oh if you didn't
get home I don't talk to you like you
know more in like well at MIT especially
and like at Harvard MIT where I had a
chance to study and anywhere in the
world every person is like so unique and
I always think about you know like
socratis sitting there and thinking
about life and you know a small me here
trying to do something with my life and
I'm just like I don't know how many
years 20 years old like maybe by the end
of his life he wouldn't have all the
secrets of you know like what life is
more than I do even though like he might
be like so much better than I am i he's
the philosopher and everything so every
one of us have the chance and every one
of us is like a super cool and amazing
person so I mean my conversation to a
students just kind of like are very like
directed because there is no I'm sorry
there is no time to [ __ ] there is no
time to you know any hi how are you
what's up there's more you know like
okay let's set up a time I like you
glutes common talk until 6:00 a.m. about
the coolest thing yeah
and some people like my and the earliest
stages of my friendships was like my
friend was like look at the people that
I am inspired Morstan linked with who
would continue our interactions it was a
little bit intimidating for them because
I mean I would just go like deep in
their souls like that's a collage eclis
if you like oh right I think like who
are they what you went through your life
they're like how the [ __ ] did you know
like I never talked to anyone about this
I only talked about this stuff only when
I'm like super drunk at a party was you
know like the best friend of mine like
why you are making eye contact with me
why are you trying to like know the
stuff like can't we just like talk about
her classes so for me what's important
it's just kind of like really know the
person like try to if there is any way
that I easily can bring light to his
life do that I really think that it's
very important to have that because that
helps me probably that's a little bit
selfish to like continue being in love
with the world in this enlightened state
that continues having giving the
opportunity to you know make those
connections and those connections are
more powerful than anything else
because this person might be not you
know like something today but he could
might become something else later or
this same honest you know approach
helped me to kind of like be very you
know good friends with people who March
older than me or much more accomplished
and I you know I I I would never think
shout out shout out to that that's an
entire show that's so crucial if if you
carried that mentality throughout your
life of shattering through surface-level
conversations getting deep to the
psyches of people quickly that will take
you so far so fast and people that are
older than you people that are that are
more accomplished in some ways they will
want to talk to you because you will be
more interested in who they are and what
they care about and why they care about
those things then they'll tell by the
way that you listen by the way that you
paraphrase by the way that you ask more
questions and get deeper into their
souls and I like how you how you brought
that up as something that
that that more and more hopefully young
people can start embodying into their
culture and into their lives because who
nobody really cares about the three
beers that you drank on Thursday with
someone else talking about the weather
no no no how about the conversation
about what is the core driving principle
of your life not weather yeah so
sometimes that you know like people try
to like have those conversations I've
said their work work it's really like
you know sucking everything every energy
you have like it's filling your Google
Calendar it was like a lot of to do
things and then you have just a little
bit free time so you kind of try to like
turn off your brain something that also
happens with me like I try to like just
fill myself with things because I'm
sometimes afraid to just talk to myself
because I know the moment I talk to
myself I need to make like radical
changes and sometimes you know it's
scary to make those changes because it's
like brings you out of the conference
own it makes you to say no to some
people in your life it makes you to say
no to some projects it's comfortable to
continue just because you know if you
really like honestly talk to yourself
you will like you know you know that you
see the value of those things you see
like you know you have the gut feeling
the intuition I don't know where it
comes from and how scientifically I can
explain that but I mean I absolutely not
perfect than that I am still learning
how to do that how to say no to things
and how to how to talk to myself and how
to like force myself to find time to
talk to myself and then this
conversations also are like one of the
ways to like force yourself to like
answer those questions because you know
think sitting down for a minute like it
what am i doing like why mine was this
person why am i you know like choosing
this path what why am i think it's
fellowships or like this companies are
this clubs or whatever why not something
else why don't I just stop for a second
and just do something that my gut
feeling tells me to do
man that internal dialogue oh it's so
crucial it's so crucial one has got to
love oneself and if you truly love
yourself you will have those hard
dialogues with yourself we so frequently
see people saying things like I know I'm
unhealthily addicted to this thing and
then they're not taking the action
that's needed to get themselves away
from that distraction and those sort of
we like to call them clouds these clouds
of addictions that we sort of that we
put up prevent this beautiful sunlight
from coming and giving us love this
collective love that we actually have
because we put up the clouds that get in
the way and it's so crucial for self
development especially in a time of like
the early 20s of like discovering
oneself the hedonistic feeling of the
void of meaning with with drugs alcohol
with Netflix with with doing more things
that you think are actually help eating
recently we had a friend that like went
over to the kitchen and then realized
that they took something out of the
kitchen started and they were like I'm
not even hungry I was just looking for
something to do like we have the
abundance of food to such a degree that
we eat food when were bored oh my gosh
well those a long times I mean again
like so many things like that comes in
complexes
I was recently in South Africa thanks to
that opportunity and I randomly decided
to climb the mountain and I'm very
afraid of height and I hate like you
know doing something very crazy like
that because it's kind of like playing
with your life and you've done a lot of
crazy things in your life leading to get
you here so this isn't better than crazy
yeah and I've been like climbing that
thing and I'm just like so scared and at
the time I didn't have any water and
like I only had like sparkling water in
a heat sparkling water and a
I thought and I'm already on the top and
they so late that I still need so much
and that part it's like so much more
dangerous and you know those kind of
situations just putting yourself up in
the munchin and knowing that there is no
helicopter that he's gonna save you that
you are the only one or I mean again
like a friend or like the partner or
whoever in my case that was there to
like help me to like go through that but
you know it's basically you making a
decision that you are either going to
continue the way or you gonna go down
and down it's even more scarier or
you're gonna like you know do that while
you have like this where your mental
state was like all this like a lot of
sun happening or you're actually gonna
drink that sparkling water because
that's essential for you and you just
don't feel that it's sparkling it just
tastes like water and I was like damn
being in that like situation makes you
to kind of like disregard those small
things and just you know like believe in
yourself and concentrating like one step
at a time and you are able to make it
and you know same in our lives you know
which is there is there any paths and
then we can just like imagine like which
one we can be in which one we can go at
and yeah the resources it's just
something that keeps others life it's it
is something good and you know all this
like culture it was Alex food and
everything it's nice and you can still
keep it but it's not worth it to keep it
in your life unless you really set for a
second and challenge the idea why did
you keep it in your life like all this
like traditions challenge challenge
why's it in your life
yeah like Gardens things why do I like
wear clothes why do I like want to marry
why do I want to have kids why do I want
to do this PhD why do I want to have
hair why do I want to wear rings why do
I want to talk to people like is good
stuff you can still continue doing that
but like did you think actually why I
stopped this just for yourself and I
mean I am absolutely not best person to
that's right that doesn't look that
bleak keep pressing one's self with
question refine one's own
spirit that they carry themselves with
by asking self questions questions like
silly questions and then you're like oh
I don't know why are we doing what am i
why are we here even those questions
like that can drive a deeper purpose
first meaning you brought up the
mountain analogy a mountain analogy is
so good both that you got to keep
climbing so that you have a great
experience and that you conquer your
fear because you're pushing a boundary
over and over again and it's teaching
you more and more about life yet also
with whatever you set to accomplish when
you do look back the point of looking
back to see how far you've come
yeah and not to go back and say that's
more comfortable I should go that way no
rewards discomfort yeah
towards risk towards a good well
calculated way of growth is way way way
more important okay let's let's make
sure we touch on this as well what is
your what is this like entrepreneurial
drive that you have with you what what
would be an ideal thing that you would
build into the world that you could look
back at your life on and be like yeah
again this thing may be something that I
just think of at the station my life and
can be that very different later but
like from the experiences and like
thoughts today had so far like this is
something that I think of right now and
I mean if I pursue that and that's a
mistake I mean that's fine because I had
this much knowledge and that was my best
decision that we make so at this point
of my life I I mean I I did baby steps
we started the sapiens think was a
slogan for co-founder for the first
human augmentation Club where I might
hand it's funny that no such Club
existed before and no one there's so
many cool people from all the different
disciplines they're so excited about it
and know so much about different aspects
of it or people who are very want to
devote their lives to it they didn't
actually know that it's actually thing
and you know like so many things are
happening in that area right now
and they thought that is just like very
like sci-fi in you know we better go to
like some other relevant things
based on our skillset so yeah that's
been amazing so far and I think being
able to you know work with a group of
friends or interdisciplinary people have
all those various disciplines that are
kind of like surrounding the problem
that we want to tackle because those
disciplines and nose and those in this
graph are not connected to each other
and be that organizational driving force
for them to connect those notes having a
company that would allow people to
change their buddies as they will I mean
I'm kind of human centered because I
just like the living humans and one them
to me yes you know like probably my most
contribution can be for humans not to
kind of like either kill each other or
like you know be disappointed in
themselves but actually allow them to be
the better cells they are totes well
that's probably what I would like to do
beautiful beautiful
I like how you I like how you brought it
to the to the to the sapiens because it
you you do seem like the one that wants
to link together the humans that enable
the different entrepreneurial
technological processes to flourish
across different disciplines and whatnot
that's very cool I know those companies
are human centered and none of those
companies are like broad enough that
that exists today are bright enough to
like encompass all those things or I
what I hope that because of the chance I
am my age allows me to like live up to
that point when some of the experiments
they think are going to be crucial to
get that to next step are going to be
done by the time when I have enough
knowledge to contribute in this way so
yeah but maybe something is going to
happen and tomorrow there is going to be
something else and will convince me diet
I have to just go to the moon and do
some art project well what you saw go to
the moon that's right no no that's for
anything tote tote stores go to the
Himalayas and just sit there and Lake
just meditate for 20 years and that
would be the best thing well I'll do
that
there's a good blend to do between that
and between some sort of influencing
civilization in a good trajectory okay a
couple questions on the way out
this wouldn't be simulation if we didn't
ask you are we in a simulation well
you're like no paintings the most the
things that hurt the most well why does
it hurt the most because you know in one
face like very disappointing so like if
it's just a simile I mean it is a
simulation because I mean if we are well
okay so because you didn't clarify in
which like what do you mean by
simulation I will say yes and a
simulation in a sense that every time we
choose a path in our lives and I believe
that there is a portion of kind of you
know like our choice nothing is
predetermined or we would just kind of
like be very depressed so like there are
different ways and we already thought
out the way that would lead us somewhere
and hopefully made the logical decision
so that simulation was already run so we
are today living in stimulation every
second I'm living in a simulation that I
run in my brain like kind of like very
quickly okay what's gonna happen next
second you know like should I sit on
this chair continue sitting on this
chair or should I run away because
something is gonna happen very bad here
well like I live in the simulation that
I thought about before so yes we live in
simulation that sense okay I kind of
like avoided that like fair yeah okay
last question what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world I love
sleeping but what I love is sleeping is
that if you think about some things
before you sleep if you're very tired
then you sleep and then there's like
this time when you just like wake up and
I go sleep back and like wake up again
go sleep back it's smooth determing or
something and in my dreams I sleep
through like this crazy action movies I
go to different planets some crazy stuff
happens with me I go to different scales
I go to like like different like kind of
like cell scales
for like touch like different molecules
and things and in there I'm able to you
know like we think that we want money
and jewels and you know like what the
girls want or like what what what people
want but well like I'm able to simulate
at all in my brain and kind of like you
know be was those amorphous things for
for a little bit and when I wake up it
makes me think that well
I always can do that in my brain you
know what more interesting thing can I
do that my brain could assimilate yet
can I use some other technology to
create something new
that my I cannot just do with my brain
because all of those mental things I can
just run in my brain when I sleep so I
can just like make myself quit sleep all
the time and like just live in this
other world in this other version of
myself that is you know living in the
dream so it's very beautiful to have the
power yes you do that yeah I think we
all want a peek into solutions but
dreams peek in there seems like it's a
constant state of DMT
okay okay and that's us this has been
this has been great thank you I hope so
it's been great thank you
no not at all this has been fantastic
thank you for joining us on the show yes
we greatly appreciate having you thank
you thank you everyone go check out some
of the links below to sere Anoosh also
let us let us know your thoughts on the
episode give us your comments below we'd
love to hear from you also go and build
the future go and manifest your destiny
into the world
everyone much love and we'll see you
soon peace that's it yeah